hello everyone and welcome to round two
of this year's thingfield cup uh if
you're wondering why this video is a bit
longer or if you are only realizing it
now that i've mentioned it it's because
i'm showing two games this video not one
uh first game is the annie ponchi versus
and the other one hans smoke and neiman
versus shakhtar mamidyarov so if you
want to check out this one you can if
you want to check out that one you also
can you have the sta the timestamps um
uh well where the timestamps usually are
uh but uh chess players often watch both
as uh well we just find the time that's
how chess players are uh so let's dive
straight into it this first game jan has
the white pieces and in round one he
lost to magnus carlsen in that brilliant
brilliant display of of power uh but now
he faces sort of a mini magnus it is uh
the chosen one alireza firuja and uh it
could it it could definitely go either
way so let's check it out uh it's uh
it's a beautiful game uh jan has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 we
have knight to f6 by alireza c for e6
knight to f3 and d5 now but with knight
to f3 basically you are avoiding the
immediate names of indian but you might
go into
or or what not
so d5 queen's gambit declined and now g3
nipple decides to go for the catalan
opening d captures on c4 and now bishop
to g2 so this is a very very standard
stuff we have a6 and uh here young
castles with knight to c6 and already a
surprise from jan usually e3 and knight
to c3 are the moves that are they're
played here there's bishop to g5 also i
played in in quite a few games but uh
queen to c2 although uh it's a it's a
nice score for the queen in this exact
move order is very very rare uh and the
question is can black play b5 this is
what um
uh widjan is trying to get alireza to go
for and you can play it for example if
b5
it seems like it shouldn't be possible
because of this bishop let's say knight
e5 but now there's knight to b4 you
attack the queen and then you just
re-maneuver the knight for example queen
d2 attacks the knight knight goes back
knight b to d5 and now white challenges
the structure with um with a move like
b3 then let's say c captures a captures
and you get a standard uh
catalan position where white is down
upon of course but he has the semi-open
file for the rook the bishop is
beautifully placed the knight is on an
e5 square so uh life is good for for
both white and black uh however alireza
says i'm not interested in any of that
i'm just going to play knight characters
on d4
show me what you have prepared for the
for the main line and okay knight
characters on the e4 we have queen
captures on d4 knight to d2 now
preparing to uh
grab the pawn and now just c3 uh
attacking the knight and the b2 pawn b
captures and now queen to c5 and here it
looks like a really really uh funky line
and there are a few games that have
reached this position for example daniel
dubo uh played this uh against the axis
of dude in the 2020 tata still
tournament the game ended in a draw rook
to b1 was played in that game but here
we have the immediate knight to the e4
by on just attacking the queen and the
knight and it is now as of movie 11 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see what jan has in mind here all it is
of course traits we have captures
captures uh but not with the queen with
the bishop bishop captures on e4 and now
bishop to d6 preparing the castle and
the rook to be one by on
so the problem is you can't castle right
away as the queen and bishop are
preventing you from doing it exactly
that so while it is it has to decide how
to go about this h6 seems a bit too slow
g6 you never want to play that uh so all
it is that goes pawn to f5 that's the
other way to do you could also consider
queen to h5 kind of puts the queen into
the attack also the bishops are nicely
slicing over this way and also you
defend the h7 pawn but f5 perfectly fine
this is what all it is that goes for
bishop back to g2 and now he castles we
have bishop to e3 by on now uh
challenging the queen queen to a5 and
now pawn to c4 and now again a very
unpleasant uh decision to be made for
alireza how do you stop c5 it's a very
nasty move and uh well also your b7 pawn
is hanging so how do you uh take care of
um take care of everything here you
can't push the b pawn obviously as the
the rook would hang can you put the c
pawn well not really if you let's say
you play something like c6 uh uh what uh
what's the idea now well bishop to b6
now seems very very unpleasant and all
of a sudden you are playing a game you
definitely did not come here to play so
already decides to go for a counter on
the king's side he plays f4 now puts
pressure on the bishop bishop to d4 uh
occupying this wonderful diagonal and
now just bishop to e5 preparing to
capture the bishop so queen to beat you
now putting pressure on the bishop and
the bishop captures on d4 we have queen
captures and now alireza plays pawn to
e5 he opens up
the diagonal for his light square bishop
and also this puts uh pressure on the on
the white queen so queen d5 uh or you
could also instead of uh e5 play c6
first uh if you want to prevent the
queen trade but alireza is fine with the
queen trade and so ian goes for it he
says i'm fine with the queen trade as
well queen d5 check queen captures
bishop captures with check you kind of
have to capture with the bishop in order
to keep the attack on the b7 pawn uh
king the h8 and now bishop captures on
b7 rook to b8 and now bishop captures
and c8 so just trading everything rook
captures and rook f to d1 now king the
g8 alireza starts bringing his king back
into the game and now ian trades real
captures real captures and this is now
move 25 uh and we've traded down
everything it's a it's a rook and pawn
end game with uh equal material uh so
what did dion get here with the white
piece well obviously he prepared this so
he knows or rather should know a bit
more about the sand game than alireza uh
and uh
well he uh
that's where he should have the upper
hand so let's see how the game continues
siam plays rook d5 already he's
attacking the uh pawn here which is uh
undefended but already instead of
defending it just goes to rook to b4 he
goes after the c for pawn and we have a
trade captures here captures on g3
captures in g3 and the rook captures uh
on c4 uh that was h captures on g3 not f
captures and g3 in case some of you are
only listening
uh we have rook to a5 now going after
the a6 pawn and rook the c6 now it is a
defense and now again it's equal
material but
you of course can feel that white will
always be better uh white has two pawn
islands black has three pawn island so
yeah and usually when you have more porn
islands your position is weaker there
are exceptions to this but if it's a
rook end game of course it's much easier
for the rook to gobble up pawns if there
are more pawn islands uh so here king g2
we have king to f7 and pawn to f4 now
now jan is uh simply gonna push his
pawns grab more space and see if
anything uh can be achieved there king
e7 we have pawn to e4
rook to b6 and now king to f3 we have
rooked the c6 and now pawn to f5 so just
uh grabbing more space here king to f7
back by alireza and the now comes pawn
to g4 we have h6 stopping g5 king to f4
we have king back to e7 not all that
much for alireza to do as uh
now you you also see the problem of uh
uh the pawns being broken up like this
if the pawn was on b7 then of course it
would be much much better for black as
the a6 pawn would be constantly defended
and you would have sort of a two to one
majority that you would at some point
maybe be able to push and create a pass
pawn of your own so here rook a4 uh very
important uh preventing rook to c4 once
you push the pawn to e5 so rook to b6
and now rook to c4 going after the c7
pawn king d8 and now pawn to e5 just
grabbing more space here uh rook to be
won by alireza and now rook to c6 going
after the a6 pawn rook the b for check
king to f3 and now rook to b5 going
after the pawn here and here nepal makes
a very very important decision he
decides to give up the g4 pawn so he
plays king e4 rook to b for chuck but
now he doesn't go back he just plays
king to d5 and he gives up the pawn here
but then the king is coming here and
then the pawn marches forward so rook
captures on g4 king the e6 and now king
the c8 we have rook captures on a6
and now king to b7 rook to a3 and now
rook to g2
but it doesn't really matter the the
past e pawn is far too strong so king f7
we have rook to f2 attacking the f5 pawn
and now just pawn to f6 and if you
capture g captures on f6 then e6 and
then this pawn marches forward so
instead after f6 king the c6 was played
now comes king captures and g7 king the
d7 in here we have king to f7 and he was
in this position on move 50 that uh
alireza furuja resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
once you sort of stop but the pushing of
the e pawn you play rookie 2 just rook
d3 check you kick away the king king
anywhere now e6 e7 e8 and that is game
so that is uh what happened in the game
between jan and all it is basically jan
just uh completely out prepared alireza
and um the
situation like we like i said i mean
after
after 25 moves all of the pieces were
traded down it was a a rook and pawn end
game with uh with six pawns each uh but
the three pawn islands uh uh proved to
be much too difficult to hold against
tian's two pawn islands and that's
pretty much it that's the story of this
game
ian just
well he he definitely did his homework
and uh ali was unable to
do anything about it uh now getting to
the other game as i did mention we are
going to cover uh both games now uh also
check out this uh wonderful king piece
you guys were wondering uh where it was
my usb king piece uh let me just uh
switch this real quickly there we go uh
the interface uh magically changed while
you guys were focused on the king uh and
this is now the game hans mokheniman
versus shakhiri armadyarov it's also a
beautiful one uh and uh well
you you will not believe that white can
actually play this what what hans played
but the position holds
as you'll see uh so hans has the white
pieces and he opens with c4 he goes for
the english opening we have e5 by
mamedyarov knight to c3 knight f6 knight
to f3 and now knight the c6 the four
knights of the english are on the board
we have e4 uh dropping a very very uh uh
well
not basically inviting but uh
uh here bishop to b4 can be played but
bishop to c5 is the much trickier move
and this is what mamadiro goes for he is
inviting knight captures uh on e5 knight
captures and pawn to d4 but uh hans
ready for this he does go for it knight
captures on e5 we have knight captures
pawn to d4 now ready to win the piece
back bishop to b4 and just d captures on
e5 we have knight captures on e4 now and
queen to f3 defending the the c3 square
so knight captures b captures and the
bishop to a5 we have bishop to f4 in a
very important move and it's the one
exclusively played here uh castles by
mommy darv and a queen side castles by
hans
we have queen to e7 now comes king
of course the queen wants to come to e3
so you play king to b2 you stop this and
now rook to b8 and here it seems like
you should not be able to play chess
like this but it's it's 2022 we know uh
from our good friend friends the engines
that you know you can play pretty much
everything uh regardless of how how
disgusting it looks i mean look at this
you have a an isolated a pawn you have a
double c pawn you have what is this e
pawn even doing uh but it actually
follows a very very uh top-level game
that was played uh in the uh feeding
grand swiss um two years ago i believe
between magnus carlsen and fabiano
corona magnus had the white pieces here
fabi had black and magnus continued with
bishop to d3 in the end the game ended
in a draw but hans actually deviates
from the line magnus chose hans plays
queen to e3
and it's uh it's a very very tricky move
um
for one you are attacking the a7 pawn
but on the other hand uh you might also
think but why should we even care about
this we we can just push b5 if queen
captures on a7 uh i mean surely this
can't be good i mean there's queen here
bishop here rook rook here uh the light
square bishop will at some point enter
the game how can the white king survive
this well the point is if let's say you
go pawn to b5 uh you can just push the
pawn to c5 it's not a problem and uh
black will never get the attack if you
play b4 white will play c4 again black
has no attack and if you play b3 white
will play a3 and if anything you've
created a nice little safe haven for the
white king there and now you're not
going to be able to
break through your own pawn and the d
spawns are very very strong now so
that's basically the idea so after queen
to e3 mommy they have played b6 and it's
a
very unambitious way of of dealing with
the position uh because even if even if
for example b5 this is never uh never an
idea if you if you play uh queen
captures an a7 yes you are attacking the
rook but now bishop basics and what what
can you play here uh it's just a
terrible terrible uh position now how
are you how are you stopping this
there's no more pushing of c5 if you uh
if you capture the bishop then just uh
queen to c5 and you just fall apart
there's there's no playing this now if
you capture the queen then of course we
capture here open up a discovery to the
to the king pick up the white queen uh
this is uh well as they say curtains for
uh for white so uh you don't really have
to react to this a7 idea but i'm sure
there's a also a different reason mommy
played b6 it's such a weird move to play
i mean why would you defend this if if
you want to open up lines towards the
white king and on the other hand you are
planning b5 so what what is b6 even
doing but okay mamadourov has an idea uh
he's an incredibly strong player so of
course uh it's hard to understand what
these strong players are
are considering uh but uh also
let's say you play c5 you might think
but okay let's just stop these pawns
from moving forward and then we're gonna
play b5 and win the game not so easy e6
wins the game for white now how do you
defend the rook is hanging once you move
the rook e captures on d7 the queen
hangs the bishop hangs
there's no defense here even if you
trade here captures captures again your
bishop is hanging and you cannot save it
so really uh
a fun position to to have on the board
so okay after queen to e3 we said
mamadara went for this b6 idea and now
bishop to d3 just putting pressure on
the black king we have queen to e6
mamidarov's idea is to play bishop a6
and go after the c for pawn here and
that way open up the way towards the
white king
queen to g3 now
we have rook to e8 and now comes rook h
the e1 and this is a very very tricky
move uh because now mahmud actually has
b5 now b5 is very strong because the
line that we've shown where you would
push all of your pawns forward now no
longer is that great as the rook on e1
would hang but hans doesn't care here
mamadara pushes b5 with pawn to c5 you
could also capture here capturing here
is also very nice because if
black you know persists in opening up
the file you're just going to ignore him
you're going to play something rook to
e3
and then if this is ever captured you
don't care i mean no the the the file is
closed again but c5 yan has a
hans has a much cooler idea
pawn to b4 we have c4 and pawn to b3 and
now it seems like you can't really play
this because your rook is hanging
but that's exactly what hans plays he he
plays eight captures on b3
uh he gives up the exchange bishop
capture sunny won rook captures an e1
and now we have pawn to a5 this was a a
much needed moment for mamidorf to
finally open up the position with a move
like d6 but he wants to attack the white
king he plays a5 and now just bishop the
d2 trying to meet a4 with pawn to b4 so
you again keep the b file closed
basically the entire game is about
opening and closing of the b file which
is usually done by pushing of the b pawn
so here bishop to a6 putting pressure on
the c4 pawn which of course is very
strong as the b pawn is now pinned and
queen to h4 adding another defender here
we have g6 now also the h7 pawn was
hanging so that g6 has to be played now
comes queen to d4 we've rooked to b7
mamadou now prepares to double up on the
b file to put more pressure on b3 and
now bishop captures on a5 the rooks will
be stopped by pushing of the b pawn so
rook eats the b8 and hans pushes the
pawn all the way to b4 and now uh this
is much too strong this b4 pawn is
incredible here and uh yes the bishop on
a5 isn't all that impressive but as long
as this structure holds the rooks and
the b file are completely useless so
madero goes for rook captures on b4 with
check he eliminates the b-pawn and the
bishop for the price of one rook so
bishop captures rook captures we have
king to c3 and now rook back to b8 we
have bishop to e4 and uh here the
question is what do you play of course
the bishop is coming to d5 there is no
question about that also maybe f4 f5 in
the future if if you just give y time to
start pushing the f1 and the g pawn
that's one way to
make use of this position but uh there
are many many uh other ideas if you play
c6 this is just this just looks bad uh
you have a backwards d7 pawn for the
rest of the game you are never crossing
this d6 square and the white will just
trade down go into an end game and win
this fairly simple end game so instead
we have queen to e8 you know that the f7
pawn will uh will get attacked and not
okay one more thing that we could
discuss is bishop characters in c4 uh
just you know so i don't keep you uh
guys uh misinformed but bishop captures
on c4 is quite nice the point is you
give up a piece after queen characters
you pick up another pawn as well with
check and after king d3 you play queen
b2 now threatening rook to b2 with check
rook to b3 with check uh the problem is
there's bishop d5 and now b3 is defended
f7 is hanging and there's no
good way for black to play queen
captures and f2 of course is possible
you defend but now queen c3 and look at
this the queen controls all of the uh
all of the diagonal the bishop also
controls this diagonal if you ever move
the rook from the back rank it's game
over so if anything it would be a
question of whether hans would be able
to convert this or not but it would not
be uh uh you know a way for mamador to
fight for uh for actually uh winning the
game so queen to e8 he's of course ready
for bishop d5 so bishop to d5 and now
bishop to b7 offering a trade here but
now just rook to b1 very very precise
play by by niman uh
just ready to read the trade and here uh
bishop captures on d5 is probably the
best way to play this even though you
allow white to undouble the pawns and
now uh it's six pawns against um uh five
maybe you can hold this uh with perfect
play of course you know that queen and
games with being upon up are winning uh
but you've seen uh whoever tries to
actually converse to convert this very
often does not or sometimes he even even
loses if they over push
but here instead of that we have bishop
to a8 this is how momodaro offers the
trade but this is now just much much
better for niemann he plays rook
calculus on b4 queen captures on b8 and
now bishop captures an a8 queen capture
78
we have queen captures on d7 and tao he
goes after the e5 pawn queen a1 check
king the b4 and now queen captures on e5
and this is the position that mamadara
saw when he decided to go bishop a8 uh
the problem is this is now completely
winning for white how are you going to
stop this the king will help with the
winning of the c7 pawn and this pawn is
already on c5 c6 c7 c8 there's no
stopping this so it's uh very very
strange that momodaro decided to
go for this uh maybe he was low on time
i did not follow the games um so maybe
it was a time trouble issue uh but
either way this is not completely
winning for white it's only a matter of
will he win it so king b5 we have h5 and
now king the c6 now you are ready to
capture the pawn if the pawn is captured
and queens get traded off then of course
the pass pawn is winning so queen
captures an h2 now comes queen to d8
with check king the h7 uh you could also
go king to g7 uh then queen to d for
check is very annoying uh but king the
h7 is played and now queen to f6 putting
pressure on the f7 pawn now there's
always time to go for this pawn and now
there's really no good move to play here
queen g2 check now comes queen cap king
captures on c7 now queen to e4 there's
no way for you to actually defend the f7
pawn so queen captures an f7 king h6 and
now queen to d5 offering a queen trade
we have queen to e7 check king to b6 and
now queen to f6 check and now you block
check by pushing off the c pawn so c6 uh
queen captures on f2 with check we have
king to b7 and now queen to b2 with
check of course the material is equal
but this spawn only needs two moves and
it becomes a queen so queen b5 now we
have queen to g2 uh preventing the pawn
from being pushed as it's uh pinned and
now just king to b8 we have pawn to h4
and now pawn the c7 now here shock
stops the pawn queen to g3 again the
pawn cannot move king to b7 we have
queen f3 check queen to d5 and now queen
to b3 check and he was in this position
on move 49 uh 49 now when uh mamirov
delivered check that he also resigned
the game uh as there is nothing more to
be done here king to c6 for example if
king to c6 let's say queen a4 with check
king to d6 now let's say queen to a6
would check and you will very quickly
run out of checks queen c6 queen a3
check that can be played king d7 queen
to d3 with check queen to d5 queen h3
with check and now after king to d8
you've run out of checks uh and now just
c8 queen on the next move will win you
the game so really really impressive
stuff by hans uh uh repeating uh
uh of the game magnus versus uh fabiano
corona up until this move but then
deviating from carlson's uh bishop d3
and just going for
this queen to e3 move you've seen how uh
how confused momidar was and it just
uh well he couldn't uh do anything from
this position but it's also incredible
that a position like this can be played
like if you saw this position you saw
this you saw this you saw this you know
b5 is coming i mean
of course uh you don't think that it's
possible to do anything for white here
but that's just how uh the engines have
uh thought us uh yeah everything
absolutely everything is possible and
you you can play pretty much anything uh
you know yeah you don't have to be
afraid of getting checkmated uh if it
holds it holds if it doesn't it doesn't
that's just the uh you know the basic
truth
uh so uh that's the game or rather those
were the games hope you guys enjoyed
that what does this mean for the
standings well for the standings this
means that uh
magnus and hans niemann are leading the
tournament after two rounds and they
will be facing each other in around
three that is today i'll probably cover
it as soon as it finishes uh if it will
be an interesting game if not uh maybe
maybe tomorrow but uh it
should be an interesting one i think uh
i i can't check i don't want to trick
you guys all right okay so yeah then we
have young wesley levon fabiano uh
maxine and linear with one point then we
have a point uh already alireza and
mommy they are of who both suffered a
loss uh and
got one draw so let me just check uh i
did not
check who
will have the
uh the white pieces so let me just
quickly okay my interface is trolling me
let me just really quickly check this uh
in round three uh
carlson will have the white pieces
against neiman uh so we'll see
what happens there uh but yeah very
exciting stuff very nicely played the
nipple completely outplayed already just
went right into the end game and was
much much uh stronger there and uh hans
uh well seemed seemingly completely
confused mamadara with this queen to e3
move uh but i mean uh it's such a such a
cool position you can push pretty much
anything and it seems like everything
should be good for black
but the truth is exactly opposite of
that
uh so yeah that's the game once again
hope you guys enjoyed it uh sorry about
two games in one video but i thought it
uh you know it
it would be better if
if i made it like this then you know uh
separately
i don't know why i just thought uh i
don't do this very often uh but i
thought it'd be nice as it's from the
same tournament now
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank pedro
gabriel gerald watts would thanks and
paul tanwich for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the sink
filled cup uh until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day